hello YouTube audience and welcome to
yet another episode of game on I know
it's been a while since our last one and
I've missed you so I'm glad we have this
time together to chat about games I'm
Todd Kerpelman I'm on the developer
relations team on Google Play games and
in real life my forehead is not this
shiny I swear it's it's the lighting in
the studio anyway we're gonna move on
and talk about this week's episode which
is the play games half birthday party if
you weren't aware play game services
launched at Google i/o 2013 which means
it's just about six months old as of
today so we're celebrating with the
party except that um I'm the only one
here Wolff is out and Dan's gone and
Bruno's alone gone so uh it's me here
hello sort of like all my other birthday
parties anyway
oh yeah Dan my producers here so that's
good so it's it's doubled the size of
most of my previous birthday party so
that's kind of nice anyway what better
way to kick off a birthday party then
with some stats huh I might explain why
no one showed up to my other birthday
parties anyway we're at 2000 plus games
that have integrated Play game services
it's not bad for six months and that
number is continuing to grow we are very
excited about that so yeah there's
there's our stat for the week and this
birthday we're going to be giving the
gifts to you yeah a little twist there
in terms of updates so there's a newest
version of the games SDK if you are
using Android I believe it's like SDK
number 13 but I'm not quite sure about
that I'm the iOS guy you Android folks
are on your own but you can download
this and the version of Play services
has already been pushed out to devices
everywhere so feel free to start using
it if you are an iOS developer you can
download SDK version 1.2 from the
downloads page and what is in these
latest and greatest SDKs you asked I'm
glad you asked it includes things like
score tag this is basically a 64 or up
to 64 character URI safe string that you
can submit along with any score that you
send down to our service in case you're
wondering what URI safe is I went and
looked up the RFC and basically it's its
Alpha characters digits and like you
know four different punctuation marks
and you can basically create any kind of
string you want and send that down with
your score data to our servers and why
would you want to do that well there's a
number of reasons partly you might want
to use it for metrics you know maybe
you're just are kind of curious as to
how people are achieving these high
scores and so you might find out you
know what level they are playing at or
what power-ups they were using or what
boosts they you know had enabled when
they managed to you know receive this
really high score and so you can submit
that along with the with a score and
analyze that later if you as a developer
just do a score dot list on your public
leaderboards you'll be able to get the
score tag information along with the
scores that get sent down you could use
it to create a hash you know think about
if you take that score maybe add on you
know some other kind of string that's
semi secret it'll be on the client so it
won't be completely secret but hard to
dig up create a hash on that you can
then use that as sort of a nice way to
verify that the score that that is being
sent is legitimate
you could also link to a database entry
if say you've got a game that is
primarily server based your server is
sort of the the primary keeper of truth
but you still want to submit scores to
our service you can basically add a link
to a unique ID within your server
database that you can then use later to
kind of cross check and verify that
these that these scores are legitimate
and finally you could use it to display
custom user messages you know maybe when
if you've got your own way of displaying
leaderboards within the game you might
want to have users you know pick their
own kind of
you know icon or taught message or
something like this I have a comment
here to say be very careful with this
you don't want to just take any kind of
user-submitted data you know that might
be out of your control lord knows what
kind of stuff your users are saying you
know in general again data created by
the client you should always kind of
view it with suspicion and do some
verification
so I recommend rather than letting users
type in anything they want you know have
a list of pre-selected messages that
your user could pick you can kind of
view that later and show that your
scoreboard of you know kind of the beat
on tour the thing that your user wants
to say anyway this could also be used in
conjunction with some of those
management rest calls that we talked
about last episode to write your own
anti-cheating script so think about it
this way you know let's say you use that
hash implementation that we talked about
in the previous slide right you create a
hash of the user score before it gets
sent down to our service then what you
can do on your own on your side is you
know you can call it scores that list
which will get a entire list of the user
scores along with all the score tags
iterate through those and check out
those tags right generate your hash on
your side see if that equals the hash
that you see in the score tag and if it
doesn't match if something looks
suspicious you can call players hide to
hide that player from the public
leaderboard
you know combine all of this make it a
script that your customer service person
runs you know once or twice a day and
you've got a very cheap and easy way to
keep your leaderboards clean so
definitely definitely consider this
option you know experiment around see
what you can do I think this is a this
can be really useful next we are giving
you the ability to set absolute
achievement progress this is something
that's available right now on Android
and web only we will be making progress
in another platform soon and what this
means is basically if your call right
now we have a way that you can submit
progress towards incremental
achievements by essentially kind of
submitting a delta write so you would
say hey this achievement where I have to
you know shoot 100 space
chips the user just you know shot four
of them and so on our service we would
say okay their totals now four and you
would say okay now they shot eight and
we'd say okay the total is now twelve
you'd say the user you know blew up
three more we would record that as
fifteen and so on and so forth all the
work to keep track of this data is being
done on our servers however some
developers would rather keep track of
that information on the client and so we
have added this call it's the second
steps call that basically lets you
submit the absolute amount of
achievement progress you want to make
towards unlocking an incremental
achievement so you would say okay the
user has you know blasted a total of two
spaceships and then they have lasted a
total of seven and fifteen and so on
you'll notice in that last row they're
in the in the table we the we submit 18
and the service keeps the last entry of
twenty basically if you submit a number
that is less than the progress that the
that we've already recorded that will
not go down so it will basically be kind
of you can never lose progress by by
calling a set achievement steps call so
this is useful one if if you do want to
have your client be the main source of
truth for incremental achievements it's
also very useful for kind of sinking
achievement progress right like if a
user is signed into services but they
have been playing on your game for a
while already and you're not quite sure
how to sync up their progress between
anything you've recorded locally and
what's already on the service this is a
cheap and easy way to do it you just say
okay you know what I'm going to trust my
client I know that the user has you know
blasted forty three spaceships on the
client I'll just send that down to the
server and that will you know make sure
that that the server is now in sync with
your client we have added the ability to
call some of these v1 management calls
from the client on iOS and of course web
so what does this mean this means that
within your game you can now create your
own little you know QA view controller
and within there you can make some calls
to for instance here reset scores for
that particular player on a particular
leaderboard you know you've got a you
got your QA
person who has managed to get some
amazing high score possibly by finding a
bug in your game and you want to make
sure you know they can kind of reset and
try again
see if they can reproduce the bug they
can call this reset call to reset that
score we also have a similar call to
reset an achievement this is especially
helpful for testing right you've got
your your QA person that is trying to
earn management they do it once if they
want to try and do it again the easiest
way would again from within your app
setup set up something that can make
this call directly and we also have
another method to reset all achievements
again very useful for testing remember
again that these calls only work if your
tester account is listed in this testing
access part of the developer console so
do make sure that you make sure that
that your QA people are listed here
because they will be the only ones that
are allowed to make these v1 Management
calls
finally there's a few other fixes here
and there on the iOS side we have made
some fixes to the widget so that they
they work properly in iOS 7 there were
some crashing issues before sorry about
that everything should be good now in
iOS 7 we've also added some fixes so
that the library behaves better if
you're using that as well as Google
Analytics on the Android side there's
been a number of fixes around
multiplayer even if you're not going to
make use of any of these other features
that we've talked about if you do have a
multiplayer game I strongly encourage
you to recompile your app with the
latest SDK because it there are a number
of multiplayer fixes that that have been
made that I think will make your game
better and finally for for those of you
who can't get enough of me and are
wondering you know hey what happened to
those I oh s screencasts that you were
doing don't worry there's more on their
way
eventually I'm still around I just got
pulled off onto a top-secret project for
for a couple weeks but hopefully now
that that's over and I have a little
more time to think about games again
I'll be getting back into the screen
screencasts which would be good except
my hard drives full video files it turns
out they they take up a lot of space so
I guess as soon as I delete some of
those steam games that are taking up on
my harddrive space all I'll go and make
some more screencasts so uh thanks very
much developers I'm gonna go off and I
guess sit in the corner and drink like
all my other birthdays and we'll see you
in a couple weeks bye